make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back today with another
installment of our quest to eliminate as
many superheroes and super villains as
we can
and today we're taking on one of the
heaviest hitters in marvel comics albeit
a character i don't actually want to
kill we're going to kill blue marvel all
right i know it's terrible i know it's
terrible
right what we're going to uh so blue
marvel was created by kevin graveaux and
debuted in adam legend of blue marvel
number one in 2008. now this guy is adam
brashear who was both a gifted athlete
and scholar and was a standout football
player
at the prestigious cornell university
now after completing his studies he
enlisted the marine corps
and fought in the korean war becoming a
highly decorated soldier and when the
war is over adam takes a job overseeing
an experiment attempting to create a
bridge to the negative zone with the
goal of harnessing the anti-matter that
comprises the negative zone as a source
of energy and so the reactor that adam's
team is using explodes exposing him to
huge quantities of radiation
transforming him into a human antimatter
reactor as a result of this adam gains a
variety of new powers and begins
operating as the superhero known as blue
marvel now blue marvel becomes widely
loved and celebrated by the american
public until his mask is cracked in
battle revealing that he's actually an
african american
and so president kennedy awards adam the
presidential medal of freedom for his
heroic acts as a blue marvel
but on the same day ask him to cease
operations as a superhero because the
public is not ready
to accept a black superhero and so the
government puts out a statement that
blue marvel dies in a battle
saving the earth from invading aliens
but in reality adam quietly retires and
leads a normal life where he works as a
physics professor gets married
and then raises a family now he's
finally pulled back into the superhero
game when he's asked by tony stark to
aid earth superheroes in defeating
anti-man
a former colleague of adams who was also
given powers by the same explosion adam
was exposed to the issue here is that
not only is anti-man unstable meaning he
phases in and out between the negative
zone and earth but anti-man kills adam's
wife and is ultimately defeated and
following this
adam resumes his career as blue marvel
joining luke cage's mighty avengers
first and then later the ultimates now
as i said earlier
blue marvel is one of the heaviest
hitters in marvel comics and that's
because he's one of several superman
analogs that marvel's introduced over
the years and has a very similar power
set to superman
for instance he has super strength with
no known upper limit and demonstrated
this in his battle with the invading
alien fleet that i'd mentioned earlier
when he would pick up entire spacecrafts
and throw them at the other ships he was
also able to carry a meteor the size of
the state of kansas
and threw the medal given to him by
president kennedy so hard that it would
have split the moon
in two according to the watcher neymar
observed that blue marvel's punches
rival those of thor and hulk and one of
his punches sent the sentry an
incredibly powerful character in his own
right into orbit
blue marvel's strength is rivaled only
by his durability as he's nearly
invulnerable to damage he can survive
incredibly strong blunt force impacts
and is unfazed by extremes and
temperature and pressure as his body is
now a stable antimatter reactor he does
not rely on
air food or water to survive and can
survive the vacuum of space with no
specialized equipment he's also survived
a blast from nova punches from the
sentry and even the detonation of
nuclear missiles and hydrogen bombs
as for his other powers blue marvel has
superhuman senses and reflexes and is
able to fly by manipulating the
gravitational and electromagnetic fields
around him when he's in flight he's able
to fly faster than the speed of sound
and has achieved a velocity high enough
to overcome earth's gravitational pull
he's also able to harness and manipulate
energy on a massive scale he was able to
channel enough energy to carol danvers
to allow her to achieve her binary form
which is said to equal the amount of
energy contained in a star
and is capable of destroying an entire
planet so the question becomes this
how does one go about killing someone
this powerful well it's not going to be
easy as he's practically impervious to
harm from conventional means meaning
we're not going to be able to do
something like use conventional weaponry
or blunt force to get the job done and
so we're just going to have to get a
little bit creative in how we go about
taking out the blue marble and i think
the first step we can take
is to analyze what weaknesses and
limitations he might have
and formulate a plan around those and so
as i stated earlier blue marble is
basically a human antimatter reactor
which allows him to produce an insane
amount of energy but although his energy
reserves are vast they are not infinite
and for all the energy that he expends
his body has to replace it at the same
rate or he'll begin to suffer fatigue
which has happened on the occasion
that he expended massive amounts of
energy and so theoretically if we could
place him in a situation where he needed
to expend
such a quantity of energy that his body
couldn't instantly replace it he would
become more vulnerable to attacks due to
the energy that fuels his strength and
durability being depleted so to do this
we would need to create a situation
where he is facing another being of
immense power and so it may not be
practical
however what could work would be the
creation of some sort of device that
would siphon off the anti-matter energy
from blue marvel and basically have the
same effect of decreasing his durability
and leaving him susceptible to more
conventional attacks
as powerful as blue marvel is he does
have other weaknesses for instance he
has been shown to have at least
some vulnerability to magic as a
sorcerer was able to prevent him from
moving on one occasion however we don't
know how far this vulnerability goes or
how powerful a spell we would need to
get the job done something that i think
presents a more interesting method is
his weakness to a substance known as
neutronium which exists within a region
between realities called exospace or the
neutral zone
this region was actually discovered by
blue marvel himself while searching for
his son
that had been stranded there blue marvel
also theorized that neutronium a
material abundant in the neutral zone is
a byproduct
of the creation of the universe and
describes it as crystals of frozen
space-time and when he enters the
neutral zone he must wear a suit of
armor that allows him to survive there
for mere minutes at a time
and so as durable as blue marvel is he's
extremely vulnerable to neutronium which
gives us our best shot at taking him out
if we can somehow sabotage his
exploration armor so that it does not
provide the necessary protection when he
enters the neutral zone or more
proactively find a way to create a
weapon made from neutronium or that
projects neutronium at blue marvel i
think we have a very good chance
of killing him but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here to thomas
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and make sure you leave
a comment down below letting me know who
you want me to take out next and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you